[Music]  there's all this talk about people  wanting to move to Mars and set up shop  and live there and I'm thinking boy why  are you doing this well I  sure for a vacation but you won't  actually live there do you realize that  ant arctica is balmy R and wetter than  Mars yet I don't see people lining up to  buy condos in Antarctica so I think the  novelty of it being Mars would rub off  real fast which is why I think it would  make an ideal vacation destination and  not a place to live unless we terraform  Mars turning it into Earth then you'd  have two earths and then that's fine but  until that happens that's a vacation  destination not a not a place you're  going to live and work it could be a fun  little excursion but if you're going to  send me to Mars make sure I have a  return ticket  [Music]  [Music]  you